what'd you get up to this weekend well I
went to Vegas
oh that's right how was it I was there
for 12 hours
12. yeah [__] yeah man
kind of Ideal so we fly in
uh with the PJ of course we with the
people no I flew I flew jet Suite you
ever flown that
um is that is that the one where it's
like a shared PJ yeah my friend was like
that's the type of [__] that like a
plane one of those will go down and it
doesn't even make the news yeah
you know what I mean
yeah yeah I've seen these guys shirts
jsx I commend you man this this
would scare the [__] out of me I think
I'd have more confidence hopping in a
plane like a jumper plane with Luke
then I would one of these and Luke has
flown once wait what Luke you've flown
he flew a plane in high school he told
me yeah I was in Middle School but yeah
in middle school with how'd it feel like
flying a plane
yeah
was it scary
no I loved it we flew uh from where we
were to a big air show in Wisconsin
what was that like like flying an
airplane [__] [__] dumbass
laughs no so we get so it is kind of
like you know I feel like
with air travel like they hide a lot of
like the logistics stuff right yeah yeah
see a lot of it everything's like pretty
well oiled and you just you're like oh
I'm just getting in this
thing and it's gonna fly me across the
country I'm really like there's a lot of
complexities that go into
flying a tube you know at a thousand
miles an hour or whatever in the air
yeah but you see a lot of that [__] when
you like you're walking on the tarmac to
the stairs you know and you see the
stairs come down and as as and then like
the bags are getting moved on and the
flight attendant is asking the guy down
there like are the bags on yet and the
guy's like looking like I think they're
putting them on now
and as I'm walking up the stairs the guy
goes the flight attend goes
We're not gonna make it then we're not
gonna make the cut off and he walks away
and I'm like what the [__] does that
mean
what cut off is there like a storm
coming like what's what cut off
yeah and he like goes up and talks to
the pilots and I don't know we took off
and very very quickly
so I was a little bit nervous oh maybe
maybe yeah the airport's so big it's
like you know you probably got a window
that you can have your moment up there
yeah maybe and and if you don't get if
you don't get in
no flight or maybe there's a bomb on
board
yeah oh yeah
and we gotta land before it detonates
and you know what's funny is like it is
it is Vegas clientele to a t on that
flight oh yeah tell us about some of
these characters I mean it's just like
kind of a like it was also EDC weekend
oh yeah like a lot of people are getting
on this and then landing and then
getting right on a helicopter and flying
right to the festival
sick so there's just dudes talking about
like set times and it was just an
interesting group of people for sure a
bunch of Agents on there I'm not acting
like I'm I'm one of them you know
like like on the flight I'm like
I'm like putting like I'm like [__]
with songs and like putting them on my
USB drive and I'm like I bet I look like
the biggest douche right now so you're
on the plane you're [__] with your
USB drive what time is your set
so this is at like 7 30 my set's at 12.
that's what I'm saying it was pretty
tight did you see like I said there's
like videos popping up sometimes I'm on
like EDM Twitter so I was getting a lot
of like EDC related tweets and somebody
was like
check out the food situation at EDC and
they're like filming the booths and a
pizza was 90 dollars
you
90 bucks
no
how many slices are we talking about I
don't know
a whole pizza costs up to 96 a street
Taco platter is priced at 70 and a sushi
platter with only six rolls reaches an
astonishing a hundred dollars
this is their EDC is just a window into
the future they're just getting ahead of
the inflation
yeah yeah exactly actually they're
Forward Thinking
that's sick man that they're at um
[__] World War II Germany prices
you know what's funny is that like
you know EDC like you know electronic
music and like plur and all this [__]
supposed to be about like love and
respect and the festival so like this is
still Vegas yeah yeah
you're just because you're an hour and a
half outside the strip but this isn't
[__] Vegas we're still gonna [__]
yeah every way we can
[Laughter]
100 dollars
what do you think is more expensive this
or Coachella
this dude coachella's not that bad did
everyone just starve
I mean do you get hungry on Molly do you
just live off water I feel like I feel
like like uppers don't like they dull
your appetite but I mean you got to eat
eventually but maybe that's what it is
that they know everyone's so tanked that
they can do whatever they want to that
number because no one's buying no one's
buying it anyways yeah you have to do
this in order to like make this
economical yeah
yeah that's the thing is we think
there's a line like there's clearly no
line for this food there's going to be
one guy that goes there and buys the
sushi rolls all day you have one sober
guy yeah my [__] girlfriend dragged
me here I don't know I don't know man
it's kind of hot let me uh let me get
the Super Bowls yeah let me get the
sushi rolls I guess
that's what it is dude there's only six
sushi rolls in that Booth right there
and they've been there for three days
yeah they're just chilling just chilling
all right so it's seven your set time is
at 12. yeah so it's at Encore yeah yeah
so we checked in
uh went downstairs hit the horses
smash
um I hit about four went up like 100
bucks back down to like
20 profit
I put 200 bucks in I cashed out with
like 220. we go over the roulette table
four four out of the first five rolls
hit a number
couldn't believe it went up like 400
bucks
wow back down to 200 200 up right at
this point I also this is sound like a
[__] degenerate right now but right
before the flight I bet on the Nuggets
game
so that's another 200 bucks
Denver they were it was plus 200 or
something so I hit that great bet
then I'm up 200 on roulette
then then I had to go get ready for my
set so I did that
then after the set was like it was three
3 15 A.M I'm like time for bed let's hit
the horses one more time sit down hit
for another 15 cashed out
and the chips are just sitting
sitting in my living room right now so I
left Vegas I think it's the first time
ever I actually left up
and you're just never going to cash them
out I'm going back on Thursday or Friday
so oh so yeah you know exact same place
I was like I mean I don't even need to
cash out damn so all in fourth and five
days but for the time being it was a
tight 12 where I left up
nice
congrats dude this might be the first
time Cody left up ladies and gentlemen
clapping your car out of Applause please
Cody has finally beat the house didn't
even have enough time to hit slots craps
nothing
after being down nineteen thousand five
hundred dollars Cody has finally
come home with a couple hundred bucks
yeah